pop
[Musique]
les collections 65 un dessin de chaval
marcel auclair dans l'essai
les parisiennes en province maurice
biraud ils sont jumeaux d'une salle à
manger pour 350 francs and feel i le
couvert d annie marie laforêt
[Musique]
moi je suis contente tu aimes le jaune
et foot être brune pas mal
berlin ghz 6 mo c'est même le premier
annonce multicolores celui là avec un
tailleur marine c'est du dior sur wii
s'est incrusté son des bandas cost et
des spirales sa marine et blanc tu te
fais si la porte et nous oui votre
grande encore un turban un corps des
spirales détient détaille t du cardin
oui et ça ce tissu en spirale temps des
roms
c'est bien faire ça du mystère
ça c'est pour mon tailleur noir déjà
beau geste là soit d'un bouillonner oui
c'est très rare unique serveur encore un
jabot ça m'irait bien ça non oui ça
c'est plus juniors jolie jupe ses coûts
il est vert oui werber pal csaky sa
garde à vue a des jambes blanche non les
vernis oui des petites chaussures je
suis bull des pays des godets du monde
tu pousses qu'il allait pêcher
qu'est ce qu'elle fait pour eux
[Musique]
sincèrement les poires oui il ya
beaucoup de bien il est tout petit
du noir notre fond noir marie marine je
lise n'import dépens oui ça vole c'est
être ramené à sa sénégal eux mêmes et la
doublure si tu crois que je suis content
a quoi comme ça
[Musique]
elle dit
tout en blanc mais ce sont différents
blanc oui et du lainage dû à de la soie
et les bijoux sont blancs c'est bon tu
aimes formidable blanc tout planche
ça je parie que c'est une femme de
courage oui
alors c'est drôle c'est court
des carrés tu as des fusées n'y a de
quoi vous mettre la tête à l'envers à
moi j'aime ça ouais pantalon
on ne peut pas dire que ça ressemble aux
autres raccourcis dimanche
beaucoup de carreaux le carreau car et
u13 en 2000
je portais un soutien gorge avait que ça
je t'aime heures
les fameuses lunettes courage et sa
jappo battant un homme droit breton le
temps au temps tiens des âmes à la
mousson s'étend soir oui en soi et c'est
nous et comme des petits fichus jeune
âge aiment bien sûr que mon avis le
toupet là où tu vois celui là c'est un
vrai petit maharaja c'est en quoi le
tailleur en toile le soir les bus qui
jolie noir de dior tous et turbans et le
titre man et rose vif
c'est assez troublant avec un turban
jaune et un collier vert les jupes sont
plissées france et ça ça jury linga
tunique
[Musique]
je lis cette coiffure
court très court et géométriques un tu
avais sont éteintes dans sur la nuque
mais c'est de 1925 à sète une jupe
culotte une robe que l' europe que
légèrement
c'est de la mousseline noire est-ce que
je pleurais avère ça tue le portrait non
moi aussi
c'est très 19,125 très charlot
[Musique]
bientôt tout le vernis des tas de petits
hindoue
moi j'aime ses jupes qui pose juste
cette année je suis ça gracieux folie le
corps de la terre parce qu'elle sent
drôle parce que ça sert à pino elles
sont des robes de card à broder et il ya
des paillettes aussi ça brille jouit
d'un imprimé un crêpe imprimé tout
rebrodés de paillettes terriblement
joueurs nous ont raconté la ruse dont
j'aurais juré qu'on ne pouvait pas
danser loin et voit ses la faune noir on
revient 10 et les couleurs c'est vif nom
assez sombre mais très asiatique de
traits comme des lacs
c'est rita nos lauriers et astrid
l'autre elles sont doués
nouvelle la plupart des femmes cherchent
des métiers les jeunes filles et des
métiers qu'elles veulent qu intéressant
or je crois que le vôtre est intéressant
entre tous et avant de leur en parler je
voudrais bien que vous parliez de vous
pendant quelques secondes que vous
disiez qui vous êtes vous appeler
mademoiselle monyela blanc près alors
expliquez nous un petit peu qui vous
êtes
j'ai trente 30 ans je suis célibataire
et je suis infirmière je me suis
spécialisé en psychiatrie
mais tout d'abord tu commencé mes études
d'infirmière à 10 de ventes
après avoir suivi les études jusqu'au
bac baccalauréat ensuite j'ai travaillé
à l'hôpital foch pendant trois ans et
quelques mois à saclay centre
commissariat à l'énergie atomique et
ensuite seulement je suis venu à la
psychiatrie comme un enrichissement de
ma profession et vous avez commencé à
vous orienter vers cette formation à
quel âge j'ai fait mes études
d'infirmière à 19 ans et je me suis
orienté vers la psychiatrie à 25 ans
c'est à dire que vous avez déjà passé
six ans avant de nous alerter vers la
psychiatrie est là et l'intérêt de ce
métier pour vous en quoi consiste-t-il
exactement consistant s'occuper des
malades dans la totalité de la
personnalité c'est beaucoup plus qu'une
technique c'est un intérêt humain parce
que on a affaire à des êtres humains qui
sont comme vous qui ont des
préoccupations analogue qui souffrent
davantage
et quand
aidé en profondeur à pouvoir vivre mais
plusieurs possibles c'est un très beau
but et pourriez vous avoir la
gentillesse d'expliquer en quoi
consistent les études que vous faites
pour parvenir au poids vous en êtes
actuelle mes études c'est un
approfondissement de l'expérience
quotidienne des infirmières ces études
durent deux ans ils sont dirigés par le
docteur miriam d'avis nous nous essayons
de de comprendre ce qui se passe entre
l'infirmière entre le soignant général
et le malade il doit y avoir une chose
assez intéressante là dedans c'est le
choix des infirmières psychiatriques
parce que j'ai l'impression qu'il suffit
pas d'être capable de prendre une prune
une température et que cela exige des
dons et des qualités qu'il a peu
particulier il faut d'abord savoir
prendre la température comme il faut et
en plus s'intéresser aux autres
s'intéresser à la psychologie et
problème psychologique et humain il me
faut
il faut surtout pouvoir supporter de de
comprendre son propre comportement enfin
ne pas ne pas souffrir de une
investigation continuer oui c'est à dire
si je vous comprends bien vous même
l'infirmière psychiatrique vous-même
devait travailler sur vous afin en somme
d'être une sorte de potentiel qui
apporter quelque chose aux malades par
votre personnalité par votre propre
comportement
c'est à dire que pour comprendre les
autres il faut avant tout se comprendre
soi-même si on veut être objectif
c'est surtout pour ça il faut se dégager
de soi tout en se connaissant bien oui
pour pouvoir pénétrer dans la
personnalité des autres et les aider eux
à réseau dans leurs difficultés pour
être suffisamment présent pour les
autres est suffisamment ouvert est
sensible à leurs problèmes
oui et cela il me semble extrêmement
difficile que là cela s'obtiennent par
des études noir sur blanc avec des
livres avec elle ce ne sont pas des
études didactique ce sont c'est un
enseignement sous forme de discussions
et des échanges discussions avec
d'autres infirmières d'autres avec les
médecins avec les médecins et les
éducateurs avec toutes les personnes qui
s'occupent des mêmes malades pour
exercer l mettez vous bien c'est il faut
à la fois être capable d'être
parfaitement soi même dans la vie et
d'en sortir pour s'adapter aux malades
certaine il faut être dans la vie pour
savoir dans quoi la vie a fait défaut à
ces êtres là oui il me pourrait être une
bonne manière il faut avant tout être
une femme épanouie enfin le plus
possible en somme
il me semble très intéressant de surgy
que une affirmé applicatifs d'une femme
qui pratiquement peuvent parfaitement se
marier avoir des enfants c'est ou plutôt
recommandée c'est plutôt recommandée
effectivement c'est c'est bon pour le
pour le travail de cette infirmière et
la psychiatrie est un enrichissement
pour sa vie privée et d'après ce que je
crois que votre vos heures vos horaires
contribue justement à vous permettre
d'avoir votre vie en dehors des moments
que vous passez avec les malades
certainement les l'horaire des
infirmières de choisy est organisée de
façon keynes et plusieurs jours de repos
pouvoir sont allés voir d'autres gens
d'autres choses sortir avoir une vie
personnelle mais personnel est
parfaitement normal
au banc d'essai les chefs 65 par nîmes
moati
[Musique]
boisseau cette chaise de cuisine qui se
ressemblent comme désert presque
jumelles c'est à la jumelle justement
nous avons ausculté pour savoir ce qui
justifiait la différence de prix de 20 à
86 francs à vous de les juger dans leurs
sept petits tours sur pied chromé 20
francs vraiment pas cher mais attention
pas très confortable et n'existent pas
en rouge
[Musique]
30 franke plus confortable mais
attention n'existe qu'en deux couleurs
merisier et tech
40 francs l'étude du dossier sont
incurvés mais attention la différence de
prix ne se justifie pas 49 francs
confortable et très élégante
attention la résistance n'est pas à
toute épreuve
[Musique]
60 francs confortable avec sa cousine et
plastique mais attention plus fragiles
[Musique]
83 francs lourdes stable et solide
les dossiers sont montés avec écoute
attention à leschères 86 francs parfaite
en tous points et le loup six escales
mois tous attention attention elle est
chère cher cher
[Musique]
tu vois c'est accepter de partir en
province on n'en serait pas là à
regarder on est bouché là on progresse
un non merci
j'aime encore mieux toutes ces voitures
je ne veux pas y passer ma vie
oui non et howie j'accepterai ans je
pense que j'irai pas faire puis j'ai mon
nom dans le nord
je me fais que d'inviter à oui
certainement moi c'est mon rêve de
partir en province
s'ils regardent leur est dégoûtant on
met une heure de trajet matin et soir
l'autoroute est encombré toutes les deux
semaines on peut même pas aller au
cinéma
y'a pas moyen de se garer dans des clubs
on pourrait avoir sa maison un jardin
soit là la mer à côté presse baigné dès
qu'il fait beau et puis pour la
situation qu'on m'offre là bas ça c'est
autre chose situation évidemment ils
adorent réussi à la persuader qu'il
s'était marié pour partager la même vie
à condition que ce soit sa vie à lui
alors elle a fini par faire c'est mal et
elle s'est retrouvée dans une ville
inconnue dans une maison étrangères j'ai
rencontré une centaine de ces
parisiennes brutalement transplantés
presque tout
on tue les mêmes pensées les mêmes
premières larmes les mêmes premiers mots
au début j'étais vraiment heureux eux
c'est un hiver extrêmement pénible très
froid si je me souviens bien j'ai
emménagé dans les leurs mon premier
hiver a été plutôt triste je me fais
beaucoup ennuyé oui on avait de faire
une situation mari je suis les suivis
forcément parce que la profession quand
même essentiel dans la vie la norme
je n'avais absolument pas choisi de
partir en province j'ai suivi mon mari
et je suis arrivé pour nous c'était du
très nouveau parce qu'on l'avait jamais
habité dans un grand ensemble comme ça
et surtout le quartier était on nous
avait parlé d'un quartier en expansion
et c'était la prison le cimetière la
gare voisine
desjardins a complètement chamboulé par
les constructions oui c'était difficile
au début mais enfin maintenant ça va
bien j'ai beaucoup pleuré
oui je suis né à paris dans le ventre de
paris et c'est une habitée dans cette
maison et après j'étais gers et de l'eau
dans un puits qui se trouvait ici ça m'a
vraiment bien changé notre premier verbe
dont le fossat consiste de 80 à paris
c'est tout ce qu'on faisait on attendait
le week-end pour aller à paris pour voir
nos amis pour sortir dans le fond en
semaine
pas grand chose chez les commerçants en
aide issue quand on vient de paris parce
que on est trop gâtés on trouve tous
très beau on trouve à tous les prix ce
qui n'existe pas en province en province
je n'ai trouvé aucun attrait dans les
magasins j'aimais beaucoup à paris les
vitrines d'antiquaires une promenade au
village suisse ce sont des choses qu'on
ne retrouve pas en province les magasins
de mode eux mêmes n'ont pas beaucoup de
traits oui j'ai regretté ou un petit
coiffeur la couturière d'anti oui
j'avais une petite habitude au point de
vue commerçants ce n'était pas très bien
équipé dans mon quartier il faudra bien
six mois en moyenne
alex parisienne pour retrouver un bon
boucher loin de la rue lepic
mais quand elle leur a trouvé enfin
quand on a tous vu quand on a fait une
install sa mision évidemment on est
moins occupés peut-être l'ennui
s'installe davantage
[Musique]
nous ne voit pas mais je ne vois pas
peut-être dépassé je suis aveugle je
peux pas comprendre les réactions
qu'elle a pu avoir moi je vis toute ma
journée à l'usiné que je travaille
lusigny ci où que je sois paris j'ai
exactement la même vie les mêmes
réactions même chose qu'à paris et est
pour moi je n'avais pas l'impression à
part en glissant dans la boule soir en
rentrant chez moi je n'avais pas
l'impression que j'avais changé de devis
ma femme
même en coop le je te crois et moi
également son fils son fils est heureux
ici et moi aussi je pense que par voie
de conséquence elles doivent être
heureux aussi
maintenant que je suis entre 20 ce jeu
mais ça qu'à dix minutes pour aller au
bureau ce qui est absolument veiller aux
j'ai gagné au moins deux heures de
trajet par jour que je peux consacrer à
autre chose à rien faire même si ça me
plaît
vaslui aller au cinéma 30 ans de
football le dimanche pour un homme je
crois que tous les avantages existent de
la décentralisation les conditions de
travail sont bien meilleurs désigne
généralement plus clair les trajets
beaucoup plus court on ne connaît pas
les rentrer à paris le soir avec la
circulation impossible
je crois que pour un homme c'est très
bien l'homme a emporté son travail il a
emporté sa vie la femme l'a emporté qu
elle même elle le retrouve qu'elle même
au seuil de sa vie nouvelle
la solitude avec moi même nom mais
j'avais l'impression de vivre comme une
femme beaucoup plus vieille d'être à la
retraite pour ainsi dire et n'avoir plus
qu'à attendre la fin mais de quoi je me
suis mis à beaucoup lire ici il faut
trouver il faut trouver votre mode de
vie
et ça ça vous vous avez besoin d'eux
quand même quelques temps de la trouver
il faut
s'habituer que s'habituer à soi même
essayer de réaliser mieux les choses
afin de comprendre ce que l'on peut
comprendre j'ai cru que j'allais vivre
des carnets de vacances
malheureusement j'ai été très vite déçu
avec l'arrivée de l'hiver
on est en hiver c'est l'humidité le
brouillard est assez déprimant
brouillard en ont le climat ne plaît pas
le climat ne m'a pas réussi du tout mais
j'aimais gré de 7 kg la première année
beaucoup trop brumeux et pluvieux
il manque un peu de soleil alors qu'à
paris on en souffre pas du tout le
climat de paris n'est pas bon mais
certainement moins pu mais nous le
trouvons plus après avoir étouffé deux
ans au milieu des montagnes
je me suis promené place de la concorde
et j'ai l'impression respirer je me suis
senti chez moi je me suis promené aux
champs elysées long des quais j'ai
retrouvé tout ce que j'aimais j'ai senti
dû recommencer à vivre que je suis
rentré à paris moi je suis une autre
chance car certaines décentralisées sont
déjà revenus
elles n'ont pas su s'adapter à leur vie
provinciale
elles n'ont pas su s'y crée des liens
chacun sait que les provinciaux sont en
général très froid c'est très difficile
de se faire des relations
je dois dire sincèrement que les gens ne
nous ont pas très bien accueilli mais
alors il faut avoir l'habitude de leur
caractère parce qu'ils aient un
caractère très distant et très froid il
ya des exceptions
en général oui ils sont méfiants quand
même très ferme et enfin moi j'aime bien
les parisiens passés sur toujours bien
arrangé puis tous acceptent d'avoir
j'aime mieux la ville campagne
je suis là dire que les parisiens
eux-mêmes - préjugés je crois tout ce
qui est tout ce qui vient de la province
doit être étape et la quantité des
viable ah oui on les parisiens de
saignements ont cet état d'esprit il
reste assez chez eux à paris nous
aimions théâtre nous y allions de temps
en temps et bien la dernière année par
un début gog et magog temps je ne puisse
me souvenir
j'avais toutes les semaines au cinéma à
paris à jr je n'y vais jamais mais le
cinéma ne me manque pas du tout oh mon
dieu plus jamais à beaucoup de ces
exilés
ce n'est pas la dernière comédie qui
manque non plus que le dernier film
sorti ce qui manque ce sont les colonnes
morris les îlots lumineux des cinémas
sur les champs elysées le soir ce ne
sont pas les marchandises des vitrines
qui manque aux parisiennes c'est la
tentation
les personnes des yeux bien sûr mais
avec hossein
à coire c'est dans ce magasin de cette
vie la vie de paris quand même mieux
il ya bien sûr cette chaîne différence
est grande indifférence de paris mais il
ya cette vie cette vie en mouvement une
promenade dans paris c'est quelque chose
qu'on ne peut pas expliquer avec des
mots fenêtre d'être un poète pour
expliquer mon marc trompe pas mais une
promenade dans le marais une après-midi
sur les quais de la seine c'est un
charme compte pas retrouver nulle part
ailleurs je n'en suis pas complètement
convaincu parce que ce décor ce décor à
chaque fois que l'on en parlait de ce
décor parisien avec nous vivions à paris
on parlait du métro des embouteillages
des contraventions dans la zone bleue et
je me souviens pas dans son décor
parisien lui avoir entendu dire c'est
bien agréable de se promener sur les
quais de la seine je l' ai toujours
entendu dire on ne peut pas traverser en
dehors des clous faut faire attention à
ceux ci à cela et c'est toujours en
critique et jamais avec
ça certaine satisfaction qu'elle parlait
de son décor parisien
je l'aimais parce que j'étais prise là
dedans je l'aimais j'en faisais partie
ici on finit la fois c'est l'ennui qui
arrive lieu peut-être est une chose je
vous ai pas parlé c'est que avant de
venir ici ma femme travaillait à paris
je suis persuadé qu'en abandonnant son
activité professionnelle elle a perdu
quelque chose la perdez quelque chose
qui lui appartenaient certainement une
femme qui travaille en province n'a pas
le temps de peser les inconvénients de
sentiers à sa solitude comme une femme
qui ne travaille pas je pense
effectivement en acceptant le travail
qui m'était proposé par le curé de la
paroisse où je me suis adressé j'aurais
certainement trouver un épanouissement
beaucoup plus grand par le fait même que
je me serais senti utile et agglomérés
s'oublier dans ma paroisse jeu même si
je suis vraiment sincère pour ça disent
que ce fait de vouloir travailler dessus
un jour pourtant même celles qui ne
travaillent pas finissent par oublier
leur nostalgie de paris alors elle lève
les yeux sur ce qu'offre la province
ici c'est toute la journée ce soleil
c'est incroyable
c'est incroyable ce qui m'a frappé le
plus cette carte est et on va jouer au
tennis on va la piscine on va pêcher si
on veut on va se baigner dans la loire
et on prend la voiture puis on est
dehors on est dans la nature ans promène
tout ce qui n'est pas possible à paris
c'est possible et ici je ne voudrais
surtout pas retourner à paris
ah non je ne veux pas
j'hésiterais je suis prêt à partir
absolument rien ne m'a conquise en
province sinon le fait de mes paris deux
fois plus sur tout mais puisqu'elle ne
reviennent pas tout cela veut dire que
rencontrent aussi celle qui doucement
sans lutter ce sens devenir une
provinciale
oui maintenant je me sens provincial
comme je vais à paris dans le métro j'ai
perdu le rythme des parisiens qui en
fait sans la muse de les regarder
je les regarde fille vengeurs l.sane
état d'esprit provincial je ne sais pas
peut-être suivi déjà provincial nous qui
sommes devenus des provinciaux qui
vivront dans l'autre petit province
quant au rayon des parisiens eh bien on
sent quelquefois un peu à dire que au
début j'étais très fier de mon titre de
parisienne et je crois que maintenant
j'apprécie tu m'aimes suffisamment de
choses à orléans pour en tirer une
certaine fierté
oh mon dieu non générateurs on n'aurait
pas du tout à paris
le jeu des jumeaux réalisation olivier
ricard voulez vous jouer avec nous au
jeu des jumeaux imprévus chaque mois une
vedette rencontrera ici un
téléspectateur n'ait au même instant
qu'elle aujourd'hui voici à gauche
maurice biraud né à paris le 3 mars 1922
à 9h10 du matin et à droite monsieur
pierre joue blot de nancy représentant
en vins marié qui a répondu à notre
appel
ils sont dans des cabines insonorisé et
nous allons voir par quelques questions
si le fait d'être nés au même instant
leur donne une personnalité identique
première question êtes vous plutôt
paresseux ou travailleur maurice biraud
disons paresseux dans le travail
monsieur double au chat tellement plus
travailleurs quand même messieurs une
question très précise votre santé est
elle bonne ou mauvaise dans votre
enfance plutôt bonne dans l'ensemble en
dehors d'une rougeole de votre marque
mais sinon pas mal moi l'a toujours été
vol est là pour bouger de vue dans votre
famille messieurs votre femme et vous
avec vos amis est-ce que vous avez
tendance imposez votre volonté dans
notre milieu familial oui mais ça c'est
pas de ma faute c'est inné ça y'a rien à
faire un pause il n'y a pas de doute
c'est bien ce que nous pensions monsieur
doblo un peu quand même
il faut faire voir quand même qu'on est
là préférez vous la campagne ou la ville
la campagne a pas 100 % ces mêmes
faibles à 350 5%
eh bien je préfère la campagne merci
aimez-vous les animaux monsieur biro oui
personnellement j'ai deux bergers
allemands et cinq chats monsieur doblo
certainement mais c'est merveilleux et
vous gourmands gourmets gourmands
si c'est aimer plus que de raison
certaines chances doit être gourmand et
monsieur doblo ça m'arrive de temps en
temps mais une question charmante aimez
vous la musique j'adore là mais je ne
peux pas vivre sans musique
monsieur doblo alors là j'adore la
musique êtes vous sensible et rêveur
oui je pense que oui mais ça peut
paraître prétentieux mais effectivement
sensible rêveur je suis monsieur doubl'ô
je suis les deux yeux rêveurs et
sensible etes-vous débrouillards me
gênait beaucoup ont beau petit peu quand
même bien si l'on devait vous classer
dans les officiers ou les simples
soldats
votre tempérament vous entraînerait de
quel côté dans le civil
monsieur doblo tout droit en prison à
et bien si vous devez prendre le train
ou accepter un travail
est-ce que vous pouvez vous décider sur
l'heure où ce qu'il vous faut un long
temps de réflexion
si l'afer est intéressante je répare
lance à partir vite sur l'or sur l'heure
et bien messieurs je crois que
maintenant nous allons interrompre ce
petit jeu vous demander de venir nous
rejoindre
voilà et bien voilà monsieur virent aux
arrêts et bien comme disait le chef de
garde l'âme athènes est ce que ça
concorde
je crois que l'expérience est
intéressante et qu'elle demanderait à
être renouvelée mais je vais tout de
même vous remercier d'être venu et
j'espère que monsieur doblo est content
d'avoir fait la connaissance de son
jumeau même au caractère commencé et
c'est vrai qu'à dix minutes près on est
vraiment des jumeaux un taux moins
parleurs et par le jour layan de
l'essence il ya quand même trois cents
kilomètres qui nous séparent et sur la
wii et comme on ne saura jamais si on a
répondu la même chose alors nous sommes
en plein suspense
en tout cas je suis très heureux de vous
avoir vu en tout cas envoyé avec un jour
annoncée je vous remercie
au revoir et bien pour vous il n'y avait
pas de suspense vous avez entendu les
deux réponses et vous pouvez juger si
l'expérience est concluante nous
l'attendrons la prochaine fois avec dany
robin et sa jumelle imprévus
si vous êtes né le 14 avril 1927 vers 4
heures du matin dans la région
parisienne
vous êtes la jumelle de dany robin alors
écrivez-nous vita dim dam dom maison de
rtf à paris merci avez-vous votre carte
de sang est ce qu'on va laisser votre
groupe sanguin
non non
oui bon aux équipes
voyez longtemps vous l'avez un an
oui j'avais sur moi oui vous savez de
mémoire au positif à n'en finit pas du
tout là jamais tresserre non ouais c'est
vrai donc un regard vous l'avez jamais
pu faire non vous savez que c'est
important que l'accident
oui non non non vous voyez pas d'ordre à
6,7 à tort bien si vous avez peur de
vendée alors oui à bien merci
vous le connaissez vous la demoiselle
votre propre nom et ça je regrette
beaucoup
oui oui mais qu'est ce que c'est à
positif
non malheureusement pas je sais c'est
une faute mais je ne le connais pas bien
le gars de la voir mais je crois d sais
pas
est-ce que c'est marqué dans votre sac
oui c'est pas marqué merci vous pouvez
faire établir la carte de votre groupe
sanguin dans n'importe quel hôpital ou
centres de transfusion sanguine
gratuitement ou alors dans un
laboratoire est commandée par votre
médecin
ils sont mariés depuis huit jours il a
20 ans il est étudiant
elle a 16 ans elle est secrétaire il
rêvait d'une salle à manger
pourquoi pas deux roues c'est moins cher
mais il avait peur nous avons guider
leurs premiers pas alors 10 francs
suivant pour ce matelas 2 une armoire ou
de froid un peu vite pour ce magnat de
ce range
c'est
deux grands rires
il ya un repreneur à 12 francs non
qu'est ce que c'est
tag france il voulait pour ce match lui
même un lot de bons un autre abri
un autre andy francs 10 12 15 15 from
suffixe quinze de france hugues regard
lkk de france
dépêchons-nous 15 francs le nom de
on 15 france la forêt stick d'assaut les
quinze francs sur 7 moment gazprom qui a
vu messieurs dames à gaz de france deux
fronts pour ne garder qu'un franc est
bien vu statut ni à gauche ni à droite
cadre à monsieur des fois tu vend cher
alors nous demandons masante de
statuettes en ivoire cinquante soixante
dix petits 70 3 sur 4 aux vingt dix 90
prend les deux athlètes en ivoire sans
s'en iront deuxièmement ni à gauche ni à
droite a sévi lundi quant à madame
bolliet sans vie vers un pays moderne
alors comprenez
2h30 franchement l'état de santé du
messianisme l'embarras d'une à deux en
ravanche à plus d 1 20 franc garante
d'un camp de la force lancé bienvenue à
duke 235 is bertin d'enfants de l'an 70
80 voilà dix présence divine
en quarante cinq ans sur la vente non
c'est bien vu un si tu le sens lons 5 10
personnes enfants deux ans la sortie 80
voilà ty pas son nom voilà c'est bien vu
mais ces dix personnes en trois races
ovines g20 rob 330 ranger le garant non
c'est bien vu à 340 l'union cinquante
trois ans elle a reçu madame 3
[Applaudissements]
à peine nommée si je pensais que c'était
surtout pour les marchands alors que ça
monte très haut vous conseilleriez un
jeu le ménage comme vous devez tenter la
même expérience
ah oui ou non il n'y a pas de vie très
intéressant risque pas de se retrouver
avec une perte de terry ah non mais on
souhaite en tout cas autant de bien
exister des grands soirs beaucoup d'amis
puis un jour d'avoir un appartement
voile acheter d'autres choses anne
philipe interroge qu'est ce qui peut
bien se passer dans la tête et dans le
coeur d'une femme qui attend son premier
enfant
anne philipe est allé à un cours
d'accouchement sans douleur et deux
jeunes femmes ont accepté de lui
répondre
la première à 22 ans elle est étudiante
son mari et chirurgiens dentistes elle
est enceinte de quatre mois et demi
est ce que vous êtes heureux d'avoir un
enfant oui oui enfin oui je suis
heureuse avec ça pose des problèmes
mais chez heureuse façon générale le
fait d'attendre d'enfance c'est bien et
quels sont les problèmes que ça vous
pose est ce que par exemple vous avez un
problème de logement de logements non je
suis peut-être une des seules dans tout
paris je vais problèmes de logement se
pose pas et par rapport à votre travail
vous vous travaillez vous exercez mais
qui suis étudiante je suis étudiante oui
alors par rapport au travail ça on pose
moins que si je travaillais 1 2 oui et
c'est pour ça d'ailleurs que je suis
contente d'avoir un enfant maintenant et
dès maintenant parce qu'une étudiante
peut facilement enfin je peux facilement
me dire une journée je travaille à la
maison une journée je concentre tous mes
cours et je me donne à garder quelqu'un
que je connais donc je peux à la fois
m'en occuper et continuer mes études
si je travaille au dehors ce serait un
autre problème bien sûr et vous n'avez
pas pensé une minute à renoncer au
travail absolument pas au moment d'un
l'enfant et sur le plan de votre vie
conjugale est ce que le fait d'avoir un
enfant
vous vous inquiète est-ce que vous
pensez que cela peut modifier votre
relation avec votre mari dans un sens ou
dans l'autre
jeux jeux difficiles de répondre parce
que je pourrai mieux vrai pour l'afrique
ça doit être un enrichissement mais je
peux pas enfin je sais pas encore ce que
c'est que mais vous le voyez plutôt que
comme une consolidation que comme un an
- a sûrement oui oui oui je crois et
est-ce que vous rapportez déjà sur sept
enfants vos ambitions vos espoirs
ou est-ce que vous êtes quelqu'un de
très épanouie est ce que cet enfant
ensemble n'est qu un épanouissement
de plus j'ai passé je suis quelqu'un de
très facile oui mais le fait d'avoir un
enfant est un épanouissement ça s'est su
enfin je le considère comme ça je le
vois comme ça mais ça n'empêche pas
enfin si vous voulez c'est d'une part un
épanouissement pour moi mais d'autre
part certains manques que j'ai enfin que
je ressens
par exemple dans mes études que je
m'aperçois que j'aurais aimé faire ça et
que je n'ai pas fait ou enfin parce que
je parle de ça parce que c'est ça qui
m'inquiète beaucoup
à ce moment là je peux leur porte et je
leur porte sur mon enfin j'ai tendance à
le reporter je voudrais pas d'ailleurs
trop d'influencé enfin j'aime pas les
parents qui se disent d'un enfant comme
ça il sera polytechniciens où il sera
n'importe quoi enfin on a quand même
tendance à reporter certaines
aspirations sur mon chemin de croix
à penser qu'il fera mieux que soi
est ce que le fait d'attendre un enfant
à modifier votre vision et votre intérêt
pour le monde extérieur pour certains
points particuliers oui par exemple
quand vous lisez
quand vous entendez parler des guerres
du fromage de la famine quand vous voyez
les articles concernant la bombe
atomique
est-ce que cela a une résonance nouvelle
pour vous plus directe et plus
directement concernés
je peux pas dire vraiment que ça une
résonance nouvelle parce que j'ai
toujours été intéressé par ces problèmes
là si vous voulez je les ai toujours
faire ressentir
je les découvre pas ça je peux pas dire
que je découvre quelque chose de nouveau
du fait que j'attends un enfant mais par
exemple les problèmes de la guerre de la
bombe atomique du chômage du sous
développement
c'est pas le fait d'avoir un enfant qui
me les rend plus proche parce que des
tas de gens qui sont touchés par n'était
pas plus direct ce n'est pas plus loin
non je ne crois pas ce qui est plus
direct c'est les problèmes de
l'enseignement oui les problèmes de
l'éducation des écoles l'organisation de
l'enseignement du nombre des écoles etc
là je vous ai deja maintenant oui du
maintenant oui enfin parce que dans
trois quatre ans il faudra qu'ils
aillent entre à l'école maternelle ou et
dans six ans et il faudra qu'ils
rentrent à l'école quand même c'est pas
c'est pas long la deuxième jeune femme
interrogée par anne philipe à 24 ans
elle est chimiste son mari et coloriste
dans la coiffure
ils n'ont pas l'appartement est vive
dans le deux pièces des parents elle est
enceinte de quatre mois
quelle a été votre réaction quand vous
avez su que vous attendez un enfant cri
de désespoir
parce que pour moi un enfant ça
représente quelque chose de l'obstacle
quelque chose pour moi j'ai l'impression
de commettre un crime ont le teint
l'enfant est encore aujourd'hui vous
avez s'est empressé un peu moins part
parce que je mens mariton m'a aidé et
j'ai mis mon entourage maman le poker
tour m'a aidé parce qu'il me fait
rentrer voir quand même qu'il ya autre
chose dans la naissance d'un enfant
mais bon moi je trouve j'estime que
quand on est un enfant monde c'est un
crime parce que lui faire entrevoir
toutes ces belles choses
ils sont à terre et qu'il y a toujours
une menace dans 20 ans je ne sais pas
s'il sera pas mort par la guerre je ne
parle pas des maladies par la guerre par
toute cette machination de la société
qui encore de nos jours ça me fait peur
et vous croyez que le bonheur de vivre
ne me contre bâle rasoir ses dangers non
parce que vous voyez par exemple moi
j'aurais bien aimé ne parle ne pas la
vivre alors j'estime que six mois déjà
j'ai ça c'est de penser moi mettre un
enfant au monde c'est un peu pour moi un
non sens et bien caché
voilà vous ne voudriez pas que votre
enfant et la vie que vous avez eu vos
annonces n'ont pas vous vous sentez
responsable de cet enfant oui je suis en
quelque sorte responsable et où pensez
vous que vous pouvez influencer sa vie
quand même elle et le rendre alors je
vais essayer par la mesure où je peux le
plus possible et du commandant lui il
forme et l'éducation forme et l'esprit
ne ne pas lui faire entrevoir quelque
chose de trop beau de la vie qui
n'attendent pas quelque chose de trop
beau pour qu'ils lui découvre dans le
fond c'est pas si mauvais et que ma foi
il ya quand même quelque chose de bon or
moi je paye cette impression est le fait
de donner la vie bientôt ne vous rend
pas plus forte et plus courageuse et à
vis de la vie non et je suis je prête je
les accepte de la subit vous la
subissent hélas vous n'apprenez pas ans
maintenant et je trouve justement cette
méthode de
accouchement sans douleur med justement
à à la prendre en main oui parce que là
vous êtes membre d'un jeu j'aime
beaucoup ça cette méthode m'aide à faire
ça à lutter contre soulevé cette
facilité est ce que votre mari a le même
pessimisme va nous tous il est heureux
lui d'avoir un enfant il est heureux oui
lui d'avoir un enfant et c'est à vous
les aides
ça m'aide ça m'a permis de l'accepter je
suis quand même j'ai grandi et j'ai
juste avant quelqu'un roule a été très
déçu parce qu'évidemment mois mais
sachant mon caractère
savez vous allez avoir un cri de
désespoir enfin il m a aidé à surmonter
alors maintenant si vous voulez en
quelque sorte jeu ça m'a redonné
confiance is the l'acceptent
alors que sûrement sur mon mari n'avait
pas été acceptée alors vous avez un peu
l'enfant pour lui dans ça c'est un peu
ça complique à suivre et même si je
l'avais pas eu tout de suite je trouve
que c'est trop trop tôt encore mais si
j'avais eu un enfant c'est un mouvement
pour lui ce n'est pas pour moi est ce
qu'il aime les enfants je voulais un
enfant pour lui
mais comment nous moi personnellement
non
peut-être aurez-vous changé dans
beaucoup de choses que vous pensez
j'aimerais en parler avec vous dans
quelques mois
deux verres deux assiettes de fourchette
de couteau deux cuillères un napperon
une serviette à droite à gauche à
l'endroit à l'envers en tout cas style
bistro de la porcelaine blanche des
verts à deux francs découvert sans
histoire une serviette en toile de lin
et un napperon de paille doucement avec
le dos de la cuillère la fin s'est
tourné vers la table les pointes de la
fourchette
aussi la lame du couteau tranchant vers
l'assiette
à droite les couverts que vous tenez
avec la main droite à gauche mais oui
bien sûr la fourchette le verre à vin à
droite à haut à gauche et la serviette
pliée pas danser plus légèrement bousman
souplement au triangle de laulan le
grand verre avant de se mettre à table
pour le vin vous avez le temps tout le
temps d'un déjeuner ou d'un dîner qui
peut-être ressemblera une claire
bon alors maintenant comme vous voyez
c'est sans rien sans maquillage
peut-être qu'il en reste encore un petit
peu c'est jamais et crayons pinceaux
les petits tampons pour nettoyer son des
tambours sec non sont des tampons un peu
humide c'est toi bien les paupières on
en profite pour retrousser les cils
voilà quand tout est propre camp du
temps quand tout est propre on regarde
un peu et on cherche
qu'est ce que c'est qu'un crayon
ah ça c'est un crayon gris qui va me
servir à creuser davantage la paupière
comme j'ai les yeux un peu à fleur de
peau il faut donner une impression de
profondeur avec un crayon gris que
j'étale sur toute la paupière et
spécialement le long de la paupière
supérieure pour donner beaucoup plus de
profondeur
la même chose de l'autre côté
maintenant on va faire un travail de
balayette pour estomper tout ça qui est
très dure jusqu'à ce que ça devienne
d'un gris d'un gris moyen un peu plus
foncé sur le super et sur le rôle à la
comme on appelle ça sur le dans le creux
de la paupière supérieure
enfin oui c'est ça elle en remet le
doigt ça aide et ça en les soins estompe
un peu de façon à ce que tout ça soit
d'une couleur tout sauf agressive en
étant un peu sur les côtés pour allonger
l'oeil de façon c'est beaucoup plus
pierre nature et oui c'est vrai j'ai
donné que ça fasse j'y pense et on met
tout de suite leurs emails
c'est passé très orthodoxe ma façon de
le mettre à commencer par le bout des
cils puis progressivement fin j'étais
pressé par le temps pour l'opération
rimmel terminé on prend un petit
bâtonnet qui est enduit d'une poudre
gris bleuté qui a surtout un avantage
c'est d'être une couleur très seyante
pour pour les yeux et un deuxième
avantage c'est assez pour le bord de la
mer
c'est que ça ne bouge pas ça ne coule
pas
quand l'opération est terminée à
l'intérieur de l'oeil des deux côtés on
attaque la paupière supérieure de la
même façon ça n'a pas d'importance il ya
pas un trait qui soit bien fait bien
délimités au contraire quand tout ça est
fini on attaque le sourcil toujours au
crayon gris de débris tout et tout et
gray sauf ce trek je fais en ce moment
qui est une couleur bistre est marron
l'agent fait en dessous parce que j'en
ai public l'autre je fais ce monde d'un
côté et ceux très marron le bis treki
les creuse davantage parce que c'est
vrai on a l'impression que c'est très
très très foncé alors qu'au naturel se
voit pas tellement redessine bien ce
dessin voilà la chose fini
j'ai pas l'air gai mais vous savez ce
n'est pas ça ne fait pas mal
[Musique]